der presseinformation jetzt eine
einweisung die antwort dann wäre planen
dass man von 39 in der erzherzog johann
kasernenstraße fand am 29 jänner 2014
die präsentation erste
erfahrungsberichte zum modellversuch der
grundwehrdiener ausbildung neu statt
zusätzlich zum pflicht modul
katastrophenhilfe für jeden
grundwehrdiener kann zwischen fünf
wahlpflicht modulen gewählt werden
im modul sport mix wird eine deutliche
erhöhung der körperlichen
leistungsfähigkeit angestrebt vertiefen
die erste hilfe erhöht das
selbstvertrauen und bringt routine im
umgang mit kritischen ereignissen im
modul schießen wird die handhabung von
infanteriewaffen geliebt dem sprachmodul
kann zum beispiel auch ein
sprachzertifikat in englisch erreicht
werden das modul führungsausbildung soll
zur wahrnehmung einfacher
führungsaufgaben bewegen und
verantwortungsbewusstsein wecken ob das
militär ihn leid contact boxing gewählt
das ist neben den sportarten mix 1 mit
schwerpunkt eben sport das einmal von
grund auf ausgebildet worden die meisten
von unserem know me was mit kampfsport
zu tun gehabt und man hat keinen sinn
jetzt eigentlich richtig gute sportler
transporte es wird das bewusstsein für
die militärischen kernaufgaben
geschaffen die ausbildung soll auch im
zivilen leben von nutzbringend
anzuwenden sein und den fähigkeiten und
interessen der grundwehrdiener gerecht
werden
das sportmodell genommen weil mir das
sehr interessiert weil ich selber im
privaten auch sehr sportbegeistert
die spielen privaten auch fußball und
das motorenprogramm sehr gefordert im
konventionellen bereich rekrut
klingenberg hat sich für das modul basis
führungsausbildung in dieses eine
führungsausbildung man lernt
führungsverhalten mit gruppen umzugehen
mit gruppen von menschen umzugehen bzw
diese auch dazu anzuhalten das zu tun
was man will diese module werden in
mehreren halbtagen unterrichtet und
überaus positiv aufgenommen
es wurden die ersten ergebnisse der
befragungen bekannt gegeben und die
besagen dass 90 bis 95 prozent der
rekruten einerseits die ausbildung
attraktiv gut höchste interessant und
uns ja gut finden und zum anderen und
das ist besonders wichtig auch eine
gewisse
anwendbarkeit für das leben nach dem
militär sehr positiv sind